Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a funny voicemail about Joe Biden
snapped at CNN reporter Caitlin Collins
yesterday and then later apologized. And
it's funny because Trump never apologizes
for anything. This this is a funny voicemail.
Speaker 6: I do see Biden apologizing to Caitlin
Collins from CNN. Man, that makes him look
so weak. What a sad old man to apologize.
I'm totally kidding. But listen. Is that
enough? Look, I think he was dead, right, but.
Why do you make such a big deal about a normal
man apologizing for raising his voice? Oh,
it's crazy because he had such an abnormal man
Speaker 5: in the White House.
That is exactly what's going on.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump would never apologize
for anything. Trump viciously attacked people in
the press all the time. He never apologized. He
would always double down. And I know that it's
a joke. The man is not really mad at Joe Biden
for apologizing. I think that what the Europe
trip really was notable for was how remarkable
normality felt. It was just sort of like a normal
meeting with other world leaders. Did Joe Biden
do everything that a progressive would want him
to do and raise every issue? No, but it was just
a return to a semblance of normality. At the end
of the trip, Biden snapped at a reporter and then
within 30 minutes, he apologized and said that
that wasn't the right thing to do. It's remarkable
in how unremarkable it all was. And we became very
much unaccustomed to that during the previous four
years. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Congress approving a bill to
make Juneteenth a federal holiday. We will talk
about a baker being fined for refusing to make
a trans transition cake, transgender transition
cake. And we will also talk about the cruise line
gambit in Florida that Republican Governor Ronda
Santos is doing all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Don't miss it. Get instant
access by becoming a member at Join Poffenberger.